another week another Friday and another
round of great games you can enjoy
without spending a penny of your
hard-earned cash plus gamespot's doing
another giveaway let's start out with
the aptly titled no heroes allowed no
puzzles either it's failed at puzzles
the first game in the series was
actually called pull the invasion of
privacy bad man but it turns out the
name conflicted with a certain Dark
Knight franchise comin at you ready and
waiting similar to puzzle quest game
takes a simple match 3 mechanic and
build it out into a rich RPG where you
can join your friends to fight and
capture heroes level up taking on bad
man himself or just excavate a mine you
know for fun and there can be anything
in those mines like maybe a mine apple
or a newly burst but still dangerous
baby dragon special community events can
reward you with prayer stronger monsters
to add your monster index so it's worth
snagging on your Vita next up from the
creators of rock band and dance central
comes a mobile game that mixes temple
run with bit.trip like rhythm mechanics
it's called record run it's simple and
perfect for mobile playing while it's
still challenging enough that you'll
want to keep coming back the coolest
feature is that it lets you play with
your own music procedurally generated
tracks based on whatever you have stored
on your device that's my jam got a
hard-edged art style that's reminiscent
of the classic jet set radio and like
that game it also comes with great music
from the bands at harmonics now let's
travel back in time to 2013 when this
demo for super hot first made its time
stopping debut but with a super
successful Kickstarter launched it's
time to go back to this super unique
shooter time only moon
you do you can stop and see every bullet
flying towards you you can line up a
perfect shot borges dodge matrix-style
bullets won't keep traveling until you
take a step forward or back the
prototype sets up an interesting plot of
secrets and espionage with a bioshock e
who's in control theme will probably
won't get any more answers until the
game comes out but the simple colors and
bear aesthetic look real good proving
you don't need a huge studio to make
games that look interesting if you
haven't yet quick demo is worth your
time and finally it's time to give you
all that free stuff for making it to the
end of the video you did it the MMORPG
black gold online hits steampunk and
fantasy against each other but I don't
see why you can't just play a wolf that
wears goggles or something anyway
gamespot is hooking you up with a free
key to unlock access the black gold
online closed beta just go to gamespot
com / bgo give away to grab your code
and that's all for this episode but i'll
be back with more free games next friday
CS
I